Welcome back.
We're doing problem
number ten.
And I just drew the figure.
They said a right, circular
cylinder with radius 5 and
height 4 has volume v.
So what's the volume of this?
The volume of the cylinder--
they give you the formula
actually-- but it's just the
area of the base, or the area
of the top of the cylinder
times its height.
So it's pi r squared, where the
radius is 5, so that's pi
times 25-- 5 squared-- times
the height, times 4.
So v is equal to 100 pi.
Fair enough.
Then they say, in terms of v,
what is the volume of a right
circular cylinder with radius
5 and height 8?
Oh, you see I didn't even have
to do all this because now
this new cylinder is just like
this cylinder, right?
But instead of having height
4 it has height 8.
See I didn't have to know
that formula, oh my god.
I wanted to draw the ellipse.
So this new cylinder looks
something like this, although
I'm not drawing it really
to scale, but I
think you get the point.
The new cylinder you can kind
of just-- then new cylinder
has height 8.
So what, the new cylinder is
twice the size of the previous
cylinder, right?
The previous cylinder had
height 4, radius 5.
This new cylinder has
radius 5, height 8.
So the new cylinder is going to
be twice the volume, right?
The volume for this is v, so
the volume for the new one
is-- it's twice as high so it's
going to have twice the
volume-- so 2v.
So it's answer B.
You didn't even have
to know all this.
See you can go on the wrong
track very quickly.
Although if you did it
that way, you would
get the right answer.
Problem number eleven.
If k, n and r are integers,
let k be defined-- let k
diamond, n, r-- be defined to be
true only if-- so k diamond
is true if n is less than
k, which is less than r.
Then they tell us that minus
2 diamond n, 0 is true.
Which of the following could
be a possible value of n?
So let's just translate this
into this world, right?
So this is true.
Minus 2 diamond n, 0 is true.
So that means that we just
pattern match, right?
K is minus 2, n is
n, and r is 0.
So our n is just n.
So that means n is
less than k.
K is minus 2, which is
less than our r.
Our r is 0.
So n is less than minus 2,
which is less than 0.
I mean obviously minus
2 is less than 0.
So which of the following
could be a
possible value of n?
So they give us three choices.
I is minus 3, II is minus 1 and
then III is positive 3.
Well , which of these numbers
is less than negative 2?
Positive 3 isn't.
Negative 1 is greater than
negative 2, so all we're left
with is choice I.
Not too hard of a
problem right?
A.
It just looks complicated.
Image.
Invert colors.
Problem twelve.
If 20% of x is equal to 80% of
y-- so immediately my brain
converts that to decimals.
So 0.20x is equal to 0.80y.
Which of the following expresses
y in terms of x?
So we want y in terms of x,
so let's solve for y.
We divide both sides by 0.80.
So y is equal to 0.20 divided
by 0.80 times x.
Right?
I switched them around
too, right?
I switched the two sides, but
I divided both sides by 0.8,
that's all I did.
So y is equal to-- what's
0.2 over 0.8?
Well that's the same thing
as 2 over 8, or 0.25x.
Or, y is 25% of x.
And that is choice B.
Next soon. problem.
It's a very cold day today.
My feet are cold.
I should go do a run, run
a hill or something.
All right.
Problem number thirteen.
If x, y and z-- this seems
familiar, anyway- if x, y and
z are positive integers such
that the value of x plus y is
even, and the value of x plus
y squared plus x plus z is
odd, which is the following
is true?
And they give a bunch
of choices.
So this is actually
quite interesting.
So let's see what we can say.
Can we say that x is odd?
That's choice A, x is odd.
If x plus y is even, then x plus
y squared will also be
even, right?
x plus y squared is also
going to be even.
So this is even.
But if this is even and then
this whole thing is odd, the
only way you can add something
to an even number and get an
odd number is if the thing
you added was odd.
And you can think about that.
So x plus z is odd.
So we essentially
know two things.
x plus y is even.
And we also know that x
plus z is odd, right?
And how did we figure
out x plus z is odd?
Because we know x plus y is
even, x plus y squared must be
even, and the only way to add
something to something that's
even and get an odd number is if
that thing you add is odd.
So we know that x
plus z is odd.
This is interesting.
So we know x plus y is even.
x plus z is odd.
So do we know for sure
that x is odd?
Well no. x could be even.
x could be 2, y could be 2.
And x could be 2 and
z could be 1.
So we don't know
that x is odd.
And then choice B
says x is even.
Well, not necessarily.
x could be odd.
x could be 1, y could be
1, x could be 1 here
and z could be 2.
So that all works.
So choice B doesn't
work either.
Now choices C and D
look interesting.
If z is even then x is odd.
That is true.
Because if we add these two
numbers and we get an odd
number and we know that z is
even, if this number is even,
then this number
has to be odd.
And you can try it out
with numbers if you
don't believe me.
So C is true.
And we could go through the
other ones but you only have
to pick one so C is
definitely true.
If z is even then x
is definitely odd.
Because the only way to add
something to an even number
and get an odd number is if you
add it to an odd number.
Let's do problem number fourteen
if I have time.
Problem fourteen.
0 is less than x which
is less than 1.
Which of the following
statements must be true?
Statement I is, x squared
is greater than x cubed.
Statement II is x is
greater than x/2.
Statement III says that x is
greater than x to the third.
So x is pretty much
a fraction.
It's a positive fraction
less than one.
And you know what, let's
just try out a number.
Let's just try out x
is equal to 1/2 and
that'll simplify things.
Because really all the fractions
between 0 and 1 have
the same properties when
you take the exponents.
So let's see, is this true?
1/2 squared is 1/4.
1/4 is greater than 1/8.
Well yeah, sure, that's true.
Is 1/2 greater than 1/4?
Right?
1/2 divided by 2 is 1/4.
Well sure, that's true.
And finally is 1/2 greater
than 1/4 to the third?
Sure.
1/2 to the third is 1/8.
So 1/2 is definitely greater
than 1/2 to the third, right?
And they're all positive
numbers so all
three of them are true.
So it's choice E.
And that's all the time
I have in this video.
I will do problem number fifteen
in the next video.
See you